Okay, I'm going to show you how to add the headphone pad back on. It's very simple. Every once in a while
It'll
Slide off and if it gets caught on something
But what you do is this black piece will just snap off. There are three little pegs
You'll see you can just pull it up really easy
Work your way around it
And then I'll just pop off
The nice thing is you have to worry about any wires or anything in there because this is you know by design a very simple
product kind of cool to open it and actually see how it's just not much in there
It's just designed to be the air tube sending the sound so there's no electronics right next to your head
So what you do once that's off now this piece is loose
It's held in place by the black piece when it's snapped on
So don't worry about that being loose, but you just take the pad and you're just going to slide it over all the edges
Very very simple to do it's a little stretchy so I usually do the bottom
Side and then just kind of work your way around pull it over and there now it's back on and you'll see
These are the three pegs that actually hold it on
so
Once that's done hold the red piece in place
Actually that's a flip there. You can see the little notches or the
Pigs go so just hold that
Slide the air tube back through there to get it in its spot and then line it up with the pegs
And then you simply just
And you just snap it on and click some place and that's it
Very very simple to fix very simple
Basic product and not a lot of components to it and that's kind of how it's designed